c'est le plus vieux métier du monde
c'était une pauvre fille du faubourg qui
avait grandi dans la rue y avait jamais
connu l'amour on l'appelait lui
un jour coeur paris rencontre à julos
c'était de la rue et saint denis le plus
fier ma croûte
il lui dit si tu veux gagner ton pain ma
vieille faut que tu ailles au turbin
c'était une profit du faubourg à ce
qu'avait grandi dans la rue tu avais
jamais connu l'amour en l'art pollet lui
mais bien vite eu le béguin
un pur jus l'eau est bien vite eu de lui
un joli marmots et pour la première fois
eu quelques instants de joie
jules ou apprenant la nouvelle couru
huit chercher querelle trouva le bébé si
moche qu'il sorti un couteau de sa poche
à lui rapidement déjà son joli rouge ton
reçu à sa place le coup dans le bras
dans la non dans le bras mais le couteau
était bien long et transperça le poupon
julos enfuis quand la police intervient
lulu et est immobile dans un chagrin
profond
elle expliqua les faits mais ils étaient
près de 20
et on l'a trahi en prison et oui
mesdames c'est comme ça la vie
plus tard au palais de justice on la
juge à julos déguisés en femmes contre
elle témoigna
et on l'a cru et la pauvre parisienne
fut livrée à cayenne
c'est ta thune profit du faubourg qu
avait grandi dans la rue tu avais jamais
connu l'amour on la pole est on est le
cas c'est et des pierres toute la
journée eux le soir elle reprenait son
ancien métier quand un jour bien
l'heureux elle en comptera félix un
gentil brad tiga bien qu'il fût
communiste
ils décidèrent ensemble de se marier
mais avant il le savait qu'il fallait
s'évader ils creusèrent tous les jours
dans la terre et quarante ans plus tard
il à tenir la mer
il vire sur un radeau un sauvage de là
bas
mais félix était un ancien judoka et en
quelques coups s'en débarrassa ils
montèrent dans l'embarcation félix oram
lulu à la direction
enfin lulu oram félix à la direction ils
s'éloignaient hills était libre il crie
hier si fort que leur ado chavira félix
et lulu ne sachant pas nager et rire
noyer
on dit qu'il montait au ciel tous les
deux ans là c'est que saint pierre les
accueillis quand ils furent arrivés il
leur donna un plan pour le paradis mais
lulu trompé vu en chemin ce père dit
elle perdu de vue son partenaire et alla
tout droit en enfer s'étaient unis
profite du faubourg qui avait grandi
dans la rue qu avait jamais connu
l'amour ont la peau l'élu
les oiseaux dans les branches en la
voyant pleurer anton l avance du 14
juillet
m